Які стереотипи існують у світі про Німеччину? Я обрала 5 стереотипів.
Скільки в них правди і звідкіля вони взялися?
Але насамперед - які з них найбільше дратують самих німців?
Багато хто думає, що ми ходимо в шкіряних штанах.
А ще - що в Німеччині постійний Октоберфест, і всі п'ють пиво.
Дірндль і шкіряні штани - це кліше.
Стереотип - те, що німецька мова звучить агресивно.
І що у німців немає почуття гумору.
Але ж у кожної країни - свій гумор. Тож це дурниця!
Німці - трохи педантичні і нудні. Але ми не такі.
Стереотипний образ Німеччини включає в себе ось таке жіноче вбрання.
Це дірндль. А варіант чоловічого національної одягу - шкіряні штани.
Цей національний костюм тісно пов'язаний з Баварією і сусідньою Австрією.
У Баварії ви, ймовірно, зустрінете людей, які носять таке вбрання щодня,
але частіше за все його надягають в особливих випадках або
під час таких фестивалів, як Октоберфест.
Дірндль - всього лише один з прикладів національного одягу в Німеччині.
Інший традиційний костюм під назвою "трахт" спершу був робочим одягом селян.
Різні аспекти традиційної німецької культури, в тому числі "трахт",
пізніше були використані в нацистській пропаганді.
За нацистського режиму дірндль трохи змінився:
декольте стало глибшим, спідниця - коротшою, а талія - ​​вужчою.
Фасони, які ми бачимо сьогодні, варіюються від традиційних
до сучасних. Вузол на фартуху може вказувати на сімейний статус жінки.
Зав'язаний праворуч - жінка заміжня або заручена, а зліва - самотня.
Стереотипний образ німця - пиво в руці, в таких ось величезних келихах.
Літровий кухоль або "мас" - це ще один елемент баварської культури,
який чомусь став типовим елементом образу німця за кордоном.
Насправді в Німеччині - вражаючий асортимент келихів для пива.
З різними типами склянок для різних видів пива.
Приклад - цей келих для пива кельш з Кельна.
Звісно, не всі німці люблять пиво, але це важлива частина німецької культури.
У кожному регіоні - свої сорти пива.
Традиційні пивоварні, для яких важлива чистота пива, все ще переважають.
Але є й багато крафтових сортів. Популярність
безалкогольних сортів свідчить про те, що німці люблять пиво
не лише за алкоголь. За це і вип'ємо!
"Німецька пунктуальність - це прийти за 5 хвилин до того".
Ця німецька приказка означає, що в Німеччині прийнято приходити
на зустрічі на 5 хвилин раніше. Але, здається, той, хто це придумав,
забув сказати про це залізничникам. Це вже майже національний вид спорту -
скаржитися на спізнення потягів. І після 4 років життя в Німеччині я з цим згодна.
Але дуже багато німців пишаються своєю пунктуальністю.
І ця риса знову і знову асоціюється з німцями.
Звідки ж взялася така репутація? Запитаємо у дослідника часу.
У прусаків і людина, і машина працюють як годинник.
Протестантська етика - працьовитість, слухняність
і пунктуальність - зіграла тут велику роль.
- У німців - добрі відносини з часом?
Зважаючи, що означає "добрі". У Німеччині час тісно пов'язаний
з відповідальністю. Час - це щось, що можна організувати,
заощадити, контролювати. Час потрібно планувати.
І це підводить нас до наступного стереотипу - німецька продуктивність,
яка отримує від мене несхвальний відгук.
Бути продуктивним, згідно зі словником, означає працювати швидко,
ефективно й організовано.
Окей, з організованістю у німців все гаразд,
але зі швидкістю і ефективністю - не дуже.
Ви знали, що німцям знадобилося 632 роки, щоб закінчити
будівництво кельнського собору? Більш свіжий приклад, який сильно підкосив
репутацію німецької продуктивності, - це аеропорт Берлін-Бранденбург.
З ним проблеми виникли з самого початку.
Врешті-решт його таки відкрили в 2020-му.
Бюджет перевищили на мільярди євро, а закінчили його на 10 років пізніше.
Просто під час пандемії, коли літаки і так майже не літали.
Цікаво, що педантичність німців і їхня любов до планування насправді часто тільки заважають.
Якщо Німеччина хоче відповідати своїй репутації продуктивної країни,
слід негайно щось зробити з бюрократією.
Як там казав Марк Твен? "Німецькі жарти створені не для сміху"
Жорсткувато, Марку! Особисто я знаю дуже багато кумедних німців,
і більшість тут любить хороший гумор, чи не так?
Але ось чого німцям іноді не вистачає,
так це здатності сприймати речі несерйозно і сміятися над самими собою.
Але не вірте мені на слово. Давайте поговоримо з людиною,
яка багато знає про ставлення німців до гумору.
Гейл Тафтс - комедіантка із США, яка прожила в Німеччині понад 30 років.
Ця країна - розміром зі штат Техас, але в ній дуже багато регіонального розмаїття.
І це стосується не лише акцентів, але і їжі, напоїв та гумору.
Жителі Рейнланду люблять посміятися, вони завжди готові повеселитися.
Вони - головні любителі вечірок у цій країні.
Берлінці - все вже бачили, це - культурна столиця країни,
вони будуть сидіти і казати: "Ну-ну, що ти можеш розказати мені, ага…"
На півночі Німеччини люблять сухий, але розумний гумор.
На півдні - добродушний. Наприклад, поговоріть про їжу в Штутгарті.
Ви можете виголосити 20-хвилинний монолог про хліб,
і люди будуть кататися по підлозі від сміху.
Звідки взявся цей стереотип?
Він сягає корінням у Другу світову війну.
У бурхливі 20-ті роки театр і індустрія розваг процвітали.
Багато мешканців Німеччини в цій сфері були євреями.
Пізніше їх або знищили, вбили, або вони емігрували до США.
А після війни тут було не дуже-то весело. Звідки береться гумор?
З особистого досвіду, власної історії. У Німеччині було ціле покоління,
якому було дуже важко знайти привід для сміху.
Хоча, коли почалися 1950-і і 1960-і, в Німеччині було кілька
блискучих коміків - Лоріот, наприклад.
У 1990-і і 2000-і стали відкриватися комеді-клуби,
де могли виступати чотири різних коміки за ніч.
А нині є коміки на будь-який смак. Почуття гумору у німців є,
і слава Богу, воно процвітає, тому що в наш час гумор вкрай необхідний.
А які стереотипи приходять у голову вам,
коли ви думаєте про Німеччину?
І які стереотипи про вашу власну країну
дратують вас найбільше? Напишіть у коментарях!